transition from Donuts we will talk
about the nights because we're getting
excited we're ready the kick off to the
Stanley Cup happens tomorrow here at
home it's the Cup Final of course the
golden knights taking on the Panthers at
T-Mobile Arena Candace Charles is live
inside the Fortress with some of the
preps for tomorrow it's gonna be a big
day Candace
it really is uh good morning you took
good morning folks as you can see it's
already lit up on the ice here before it
heats up between the Florida Panthers
and our very own Vegas golden knights
now the bestest seven game series begins
as we mentioned right here on Saturday
June 3rd at 5 p.m expect heavy crowds
because the excitement really is there
there will be there have been five
different ticketing categories for
Stanley Cup Final games played here at
T-Mobile Arena unfortunately this game
is sold out the golden knights came
close to touching the Stanley Cup in
their inaugural season just six years
ago fans are saying not only will they
take it home this time around but the
predicting a sweep you guys we caught up
with a few fans at the Junior Knights
practice at CNA take a listen
I think we could win four I'm expecting
big things we're all hoping to go to a
parade
yes we certainly are and if you're still
looking for tickets here's what StubHub
suggests don't pay cash use a service
with a guaranteed don't share ticket
barcodes on socials and tip to make your
money go further again the game kicks
off here at 5 pm on Saturday I heard
there'll be a little bit of a concert
right in front we got you covered with
all the details as well on our website
80snow.com for that for now live from
the T-Mobile Arena I'm Candace Charles 8
news now go nights go nights it's
palpable the fever I think it's fever I
love how jammed practices for the golden
knights at City Nationals somewhere else
that's good stuff Candace thank you
um of course you can't make it out to
the game she did say it's sold out don't
worry there's plenty of watch parties
happening tomorrow if you don't have a
ticket can hang out at Circa they're
gonna have the game on the big screen
there admissions 40 bucks it covers you
all day or you can head down to Water
Street Plaza in Henderson it's for all
ages and it is free they've got food and
music all the fun so it depends on what
part of the valley you're in what age
you are you might want to head out to
one of those two events or I don't know
hang out at home I was gonna say what do
you plan to watch tomorrow I'm doing it
at home baby I'll be checking the score
while I'm hosting the jazz in the park
concert at the County Government Center
tomorrow evening oh you got to do both
at once okay giving updates during the
intermission in between like we do okay
absolutely